- I feel like I'm kind
of floating around like
a encouragement fairy
today, just kind of like
do do do, here you go I believe in you.
You're awesome.
(upbeat music)
Hey what's up, I'm JoJo and
I'm here to spread mad love
through as many random acts
of kindness as I can squeeze
in while I'm here at BuzzFeed.
We're gonna start spreadin'
mad love with just some
kind of affirmative words.
You are worthy.
You are the shh.
Stick, well how bow dat, let's go.
Let's just make somebody's day.
- Some girl named JoJo
she happened to give me a
little sticky note passing
good vibes and it made my day.
- Okay come follow me
let's go say hi to the
BuzzFeed employees, c'mon.
(screaming)
- And I was like, nah, this
ain't the real JoJo and
then it turned out to
be the real JoJo and so
I fangirled and lost my cool.
And I appreciate it because
now I can look at my photo
album on my phone and
see that my 8th grade
dreams came true.
- Keep it up guys, keep killin' it.
I'm inside the heart love
rainbow, and we're gonna
step it up a notch and introduce puppies
into the equation.
What?
C'mon!
♫ Hey Selorm
(screams)
- What the hell it's JoJo.
♫ I just wanted to see if you
might be happy with a puppy.
- What?
- You're so pretty!
Are you like kidding me,
there's a puppy, I'm gonna cry.
- This is Sola.
- Oh my god I can't handle this.
I feel like I blacked out,
like I want to recount
what happened but I can't
really because I know
I acted a fool.
♫ Twinkle twinkle little star
♫ How I wonder what you are
♫ Up above the world so high
- And her voice is literally
like if someone was just gonna
lightly insert honey into
your earlobe, that's what
it sounds like.
♫ Twinkle twinkle little star
♫ How I wonder what you are
- So I walked into lunch
today and lo and behold
there's JoJo standing in
the kitchen like comes up
to us like gives us all these
compliments, told us that
she was walking around and
just like making people
happy for the day basically.
And like gave us our
bowls and our forks and
she looked bomb as fuck.
- I kind of feel like
kindness is contagious because
once I started giving out
compliments and affirmations
they started coming right back to me.
So it makes me feel like we
should really kinda do this
all the time.
Well that's it for me at
BuzzFeed and just keep
spreading mad love every day
you can and until next time,
I'll see you around the
streets spreading random
acts of kindness.
- I wanted to ask for her
phone number but she offered an
email which was nice.